[Music]
mit has this
insane abundance of talented musicians
about half the mit undergraduate
population is taking music courses every
year
and they're these crazily impressive
people
when the shutdown started looming in
that kind of final week
in march we really started to realize
just
how important the immediacy of being
together was
and what it meant to us to be making
music in the same place
at the same time
so we got them all microphones and we
shipped them off all over to everybody
in the orchestra
and we had actually performed a piece of
brian eno's music
called discreet music in the fall which
is basically an
improvisation where everybody chooses
their own tempo in their own patterns
and supposedly was just to teach them
how to get the right levels
and how to like learn how to position
their mic and stuff like that but really
was to kind of make a piece out of this
like a collage
so i got these 45 tracks and i put them
all together
and suddenly we had made an orchestra
piece together
and i let them know that we're going to
have the first zoom meeting
exactly when the first rehearsal would
have been and like i just opened up the
program
and all these faces started popping up
you know all these kids that i've been
working with all year and i just got so
happy
in a way that i hadn't been really since
the whole thing began you know and they
seemed really happy to see each other
they seemed really happy
just to connect and i just realized this
is
kind of about education and it's kind of
about music but it's also just about
[Music]
connecting
then it was just like well what should
we do next and so
uh we decided that we would uh take on
beethoven that way
so we all find it hilarious that i
walked into this like
trying to do everything but play
beethoven with this orchestra
you all hear that but then it turned out
that the second movement of the seventh
symphony was the perfect project in this
situation
it had just the right sort of feeling
for the moment because it's
sort of funerial in a weird way but it
has these kind of moments of hope in it
it goes up a couple steps and then it
stays there so
we'll finish it on the last day of term
but there ain't nothing like the real
thing right so
it's not gonna sound like the vienna
philharmonic you know
but the other ensembles are doing
similar things the jazz band is working
that way the wind ensembles working that
way
it's been great and what's exciting to
me about coming back together is that
we'll have what we've learned from this
experience
which is actually quite a lot of
information about who we all are as
musicians and what our skills are i mean
i talked to my colleagues about
how we kind of know more about our
students
individual abilities than we did going
in because i'm
getting 40 recordings from them a week
i felt a little bit guilty about the
fact that it had to by necessity
turn into a recording techniques class
so that's not what they signed on for
they just wanted to come to an orchestra
and playing an orchestra a couple times
a week
but it was empowering things for them to
know
and i realized it helps them in exactly
the ways that
they're supposed to be helped as
musicians if you use this in the right
way then you can play more in tune and
you can play more in time and you can
actually hear
why it sounds different so what we've
gained from that technology
we can use it and put it back where it
belongs which is
as this tool for togetherness and
connection and empathy
and to be able to do that in a space
that's actually designed
to make music it's kind of like when
biologists
are doing the best they can to do their
work at home but ultimately when they
get back in the lab
they have all their equipment and they
have everything designed in the right
way they have the right temperature
control the right clean rooms
then they can really do their work and
so for us
we're in this holding pattern and we're
making the best of it and we're learning
things but
what we're really gonna do with that is
what happens when we actually get back
together
in a real music space
you